[Music]
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between us and uk papa john's
this is food wars
in the uk our sizes start at small ours
is 9.5 inches across
with a surface area of 71 square inches
our small pizza
comes in at 10 inches which is 78.5
square inches of pizza next up we have
our medium pizza
it's 11.5 inches across with a surface
area of 103.8
square inches our large
14 inches which is 153.9 square inches
finally for some reason we skip extra
large and go straight to extra extra
large
this one's 15.5 inches across with a
surface area of 188.7 square inches
we didn't skip the extra large 16 inches
right here that's 201 square
izzo's a pizza our extra large is bigger
than your extra extra large
in your face harry
in the uk a small cheese pizza will cost
you 11.99
which is around 15.54 that's a price per
square inch of 21.8 cents
small in the u.s 9.49 which is about 12
cents per square inch
i know i got a small but apparently
they're also doing small peppers with
the small pizzas look how small this is
skimping on the peppers eh papa an xxl
cheese pizza in the uk will cost you
around 23.32 cents
which is a price of 12.3 cents per
square inch
usa's extra-large 49
cents that cannot be right sprinkle a
little math on that
that's 7.7 cents per square inch that is
so cheap
so what can we take away from this well
in both countries the more pizza you buy
the cheaper it gets in the u.s the price
per square inch of a small is 55 percent
more than an extra large and in the uk
it shoots up to a huge
77 percent more i mean it makes sense
right i mean that's how they get you
they
pretty much are tricking you into
getting more pizza because it's cheap
per square inch
so you're going i'll just get the extra
large instead and then a year later
you're fat
[Laughter]
whoops it was such a good deal it is
worth noting that
paying full price is kind of rare in the
uk we got like a 40
off deal because we spent a certain
amount of money basically if you're
paying full price in the uk
you're really not getting the best value
for money i'm on the website right now
and it looks like yeah
they have endless specials or deals so
pretty much every combination you want
to get large one-topping pizza any two
sides
two large pizzas i'm assuming what papa
john's does
is have all types of deals and codes and
promotions
that whatever you get when you order
papa john's is probably a deal for you
so you probably are never paying full
price
in the uk an extra extra large cheese
pizza is cut into 12 slices
each of these 12 slices is 268 calories
which brings a total to a whopping 328
calories in the u.s our extra-large is
cut into 10 slices
that means each slice is roughly 300
calories
and there is no possible way you're
eating this pizza
without the sauce
what about the most calorific thing on
the menu in the uk
it's a sausage and pepperoni pizza now
for an xxl version of this pizza
each slice is 355 calories that brings
the total to 4
260 calories in the u.s if you're going
for most calories
it's a tie between the meats pizza and
the pepperoni
sausage and three cheese pizza this used
to be john's favorite
they changed the name they took his name
off of it when he left i wonder what
happened to that guy
each pizza is roughly 410 calories per
slice
and since it's 10 slices per pizza that
is a whopping
4 100 calories per pizza
so despite the average pizza sizes being
smaller in the uk the pizzas themselves
are actually more calorific
who knew
[Music]
now despite papa john's motto being
better ingredients better pizza
they don't actually make their full
ingredients list available in the uk
we did reach out to them to see if
they'd make an exception for us but at
the time of shooting this
unfortunately we hadn't heard back now
because we can't get the uk papa john's
ingredients list
we're going to tweak this section a
little bit we're going to compare the
u.s papa john's ingredients
to another very popular fast food pizza
chain
dominance let's get domino's dough
ingredients on the screen
now let's compare that with the papa
john's u.s dough ingredients
unbleached enriched wheat flour water
sugar soybean oil
salt yeast and that's it
how hilarious is that see it doesn't
need to be a whole
chemistry lab okay i got to get papa
john's
props that's really great they say
fresher ingredients and they mean it i
like that
here is everything you can only find on
the menu at a uk papa john's
and these are all the usa exclusive
items you can get at papa john's
let's start with the pizzas so in front
of me i have three pizzas and across
these three we've covered pretty much
all of the items you can only find on
the menu at a uk papa john's so what i
have right in front of me here
is a pizza with a butternut squash base
now this is on the menu
as a gluten-free alternative to
traditional doughs
then the pizzas outside of that as you
can see have a stuffed crust which is
just the classic crust
but then folded over and filled with a
kind of cheesy garlicky mix which is
really really good
this right here is a pizza consisting of
only the toppings and crusts that you
can get in the u.s
we have the parmesan cheese garlic
crusted crust
crusted crust now from there you can
also customize the base sauce
so instead of the tomato sauce on this
one we have an amarillo chili sauce
i was not aware of this until recently
but apparently at a papa john's in the
united states
you can substitute the tomato sauce for
ranch
and i did exactly that because there's
nothing more american
than ranch dressing papa john's in the
uk actually offers quite a few
vegetarian and vegan options
for example again on this pizza instead
of the classic mozzarella blend cheese
we have a vegan cheese which is a cheese
alternative that's friendly for vegans
so in the uk you can top your pizza with
anchovies
with tuna with tandoori chicken with
spicy beef
and also some fake meat alternatives
such as vegan pepperoni
and also a vegan sausage finally we have
a couple of vegetarian toppings for
example on this pizza we have some
red chillies and on this pizza we have
feta cheese
and sweet corn cheese we did do the
parmesan romano
and the three cheese blend which is
provolone fontana fontania
fanta whatever and asiago cheeses salami
canadian bacon the philly cheesesteak
stuff
spinach and also of course banana
peppers
i don't know what it is with banana
peppers or suddenly on everything
i don't get it all right here we go
all right positive mental attitude pma
i'm about to have
the usa only
no i do not like that
i admit it's growing on me i wouldn't
pick the ranch sauce
i would stick with tomato being not bad
oh god
that's not good oh man don't
don't order this don't order the uk only
pizza moving
swiftly on from the uk only pizza here
are some sides you can only find on the
menu at a uk papa john's
we've got some vegan cauliflower wings
it's basically just small pieces of
cauliflower that are breaded and fried
and then you can kind of dip them in a
sauce of your choice
just a nice chicken wing alternative for
vegetarians
here we've got some chicken poppers now
i think these are available in the us
but the one that's exclusive to the uk
is the tandoori chicken spice one
which is just pieces of chicken breaded
and fried with an indian spice blend
here we've got some tater tots which i'm
surprised you guys can't get in the u.s
because these aren't really a thing in
the uk
but here we can get tater tots you can
get them with cheese like we have here
or you can also get them with cheese and
bacon and then finally again surprising
you don't have these in the u.s
these are some jalapeno poppers just
kind of mini jalapenos breaded fried
with some cheese inside
now i'm super excited to try these these
are marmite scrolls
what it is is kind of pieces of dough
rolled up with some cheese
and some marmite in the middle of them
now joe if you've never had marmite it
sounds gross because it's actually
harry yes i actually in fact have had
marmite it was a while ago in college i
lived briefly with a british guy
he had a jar of it i did try it once i
don't remember
exactly how it tasted but i do recall
comparing it to the taste of vomit
so suffice to say i'm in the not fan of
marmite category
so far the papa john's sides game is
pretty strong
now for wings we have a honey chipotle
wing sauce garlic knots oh man
dude this thing is drenched in their
butter
i'm confused by this next usa only thing
it is
called a papadia i mean it's a calzone
but for some reason they're calling it a
papadia which i
assume is a playoff of quesadilla yeah
look
it's just it's just it's just the pizza
that they cut and folded over
right moving on these look good these
look right up my alley these are the uh
jalapeno popper rolls and ranch
forgot we also got breadsticks
here's some u.s exclusive sauces spicy
garlic
ranch of course honey mustard
blue cheese regular cheese
and you can also get big surprise
side of banana peppers also cider
jalapenos
and i was as surprised as anyone to see
also in the u.s
you can get these cider anchovies
finally for those of you with a sweet
tooth papa john's in the uk has a few
exclusive desserts
we have some chocolate scrolls on my
right and some cinnamon scrolls on my
left
and then finally we have some ben and
jerry's papa john's in the uk it's kind
of like a ben jerry's license vendor
which is quite cool
and then also we can get some milkshakes
here which are a brand called for real
and they're not bad for dessert
the one thing we got that you don't have
uk cinnamon
pull-aparts again apologies it's been
sitting for a while
dude yes to these
i guess i'm not supposed to i mean i
don't have to try everything but i'm
kind of curious right
oh boy